non-minimalists
so my partner and i both have worked in
the wedding industry
he's in catering and i've done hair for
weddings before
we've both said that if we were ever
going to get married we wouldn't want a
normal wedding and we don't need to be
legally married
i really like what you guys have said
about that and
for us we'd prefer to spend whatever
money family wants to dedicate or give
to us to
traveling internationally together
because it's a passion of both of ours
but at some point we might want to have
a party for our families just to
you know have our families all meet one
day and
hang out and celebrate us how could we
incorporate minimalist practices
into this kind of celebration and is
this something that you guys have even
though you didn't have
a normal or a legal marriage or wedding
ryan if you don't have a legal marriage
is it an illegal marriage
yeah maybe well here's the thing
i i mean let's let's talk about our
stance on this real real quick
because i think this question is
ultimately about language the language
that we use so
she used a few uh words here she talked
about instead of having a wedding she
wants to have a party well we already
identified a wedding is just a party
right and so whatever whatever
vernacular you're going to use to
describe the
ceremonial event that represents
the marriage although we have already
acknowledged that
a wedding is not a marriage and you can
have the
best wedding and the worst marriage
and vice versa or they can they can both
be great
or they can both be terrible i suppose
if that's an option there
so um let's talk about our our situation
because
when she says you're not legally married
i didn't have a religious ceremony
because
um i don't belong to a particular
religious tradition that would require
that and um
i don't believe i don't i don't like the
government's involvement in marriage
personally
and so i'm at this weird intersection
where i don't
need and by the way the government being
involved in marriage is a relatively new
thing george washington was married but
he wasn't married by the government
right and yet he still had a marriage
right he just didn't have to go down to
the courthouse and fill out a piece of
paper
so when ryan and i use the term you know
spouse or wife or
marriage what we're using is a term that
describes the type of relationship that
we have it's a
a long-term partnership a long-term
commitment
now commitment is not birthed out of a
piece of paper we can go
sign a piece of paper right now and then
go cheat on the person the next day
and i don't mean cheat just in the
physical sense but cheat and all these
we can lie to them we could steal from
them we could hide things from them
these are all different ways to sort of
cheat a relationship
and so because of the the religious
aspect and the governmental aspect
you know i don't have a a formal piece
of paper but i actually have pieces of
paper that mean a lot more
to our relationship and ryan you do as
well but
i mentioned a moment ago life insurance
you know to me that's far more important
than having some sort of
you know marriage certificate uh such a
sexy topic too
life insurance i know right it's like
and
in fact because these things are so
unsexy
we almost never talk to them talk to our
significant other
about the most important things and so
i have 20-year term life insurance ryan
has the same
and that means and it's 10 times my
annual income and
so it's about 100 a month and
um maybe a little bit less and and what
that means is if i die
in the next 20 years then
bex and ella aren't going to be you know
out on the street you know
trying to figure out how they're going
to get their next meal or pay their rent
or or whatever
and i think that that is to me
one sign of commitment that has nothing
to do with just signing a piece
of paper but real commitment is birthed
from our everyday actions
and and so i think that's why this is so
appealing to someone
like amber because too often what we do
is we say
i'm going to have this ceremony that
represents something and it can be
beautiful but then we say
well that was that i guess i'm committed
for life now
but real commitment doesn't look like
that it's it's more of a verb where we
have to commit
every day to that person because
otherwise we're in that relationship out
of some sort of pious sense of
obligation and no one feels good about
being in an obligatory relationship
absolutely and also i think deriving a
sense of your identity
out of that relationship or being
married uh i think
is is something that a lot of people
like can relate to as well so well yeah
i think that's
that's fascinating because that identity
the reason ryan and i use that language
it's these are sounds that we make with
our mouth we say
husband wife or whatever but like it
means something to someone else it's a
shortcut to describe
the essence of our relationship but it
doesn't describe the totality of the
relationship
uh bex and i were having this exercise
the other day when she asked me to
explain something she's like
well i need you to explain it better and
i said well try to explain why you love
me
right and and are you a words of
affirmation person
no no really what i was trying to
explain to her is that you can't
you can only use language only goes so
far yeah
and and so she could say well i love you
because you're six too
and um i you know i really like your
hair
and i think you have a handsome face
and i like your biceps
you could you could name a dozen two
dozen three dozen things
but then say you have three dozen things
there are millions
of people who fit that 36 item criteria
yeah and so it's not the essence i mean
it's not the totality rather of our
relationship you can't describe
love with a series of checklists in just
the same way we can't describe a
marriage so what we do is we do our best
to use language
as a shortcut to communicate with other
people so if it's helpful for people
uh in this different setting i could say
my partner
i call ella my daughter she's my
stepdaughter but i call her my daughter
because i raise her
and or help raise her and and
all of that is just language to help
explain to other people
the the essence of of that thing yeah i
like the idea
uh she has here amber has of having a
party um mariah and i have actually
thought about doing something like this
just bringing the families together
um and you're all invited if you're a
patreon exactly only the vips are
invited
they can all attend from anywhere yes
that's what we'll do
a zoom party 300 patrons just man
that would be yeah that would be that
would be uh
super affordable i imagine surprised at
how like
meaningful and and heartfelt it is to
watch people on zoom though getting
married i've
attended a couple i've attended a couple
of things uh on
zoom like a cocktail party a magic show
just a couple things that i was it was a
it was a pretty awesome substitute for
the real thing i think i still prefer
the face-to-face interaction but
but okay so when it comes to this
minimalist party you tell me jessica if
this is the way
to approach it i would think if it was
mariah and i
her and i would decide first off like
what can we afford so let's say our
budget's
five thousand bucks like and then we
would start to work our way backwards
from
what that budget is is that a good place
to start yeah i think so
i i definitely think it's important to
kind of have a drop dead number
of like i don't want to spend more than
this and it should be based on what you
can realistically afford whether it's
what's in your savings account right now
or what you can save up in the time
between now and when the event is
actually going to happen um
and then yeah thinking through the big
things like
how many people are gonna attend and the
venue is gonna be the biggest things you
kind of need to figure out to see
if you're gonna be able to accomplish
what you want to on the budget that you
have
yeah i was uh in pasadena
and there's this like ritz carlton there
and for the ballroom for the wedding
room
it's like a it's like six figures to
rent this room out for a room
for a room yeah you just mentioned the
venue made me think about that
um yeah but what are you've seen some
really lavish weddings i'm sure
in your line of work um what are some of
the most ridiculous things
that you see people spend money on i
mean
it's hard to talk about without not
sounding like super judgmental about it
but i
am kind of a little bit about just like
the over extravagance
um but i i would say the craziest things
i've heard of people doing are things
like you know the champagne fountains or
personalized everything where like
guests get
gift bags full of stuff when they arrive
you know it's just
it's wonderful if you have the money for
that sort of thing absolutely do it like
i don't begrudge anybody who actually
has the money to spend and that's how
they choose to spend it like more power
to you
um in theory but um yeah as long as
they're doing it with intention
right not just spending money for the
sake well i'm gonna spend a million
dollars on this wedding right
right it should be on things that you
value and that are meaningful to you
and should come from a place of like
heartfelt
generosity and not like obligation kind
of like what you said before
yeah amber i really love the idea that
you are
trying to live an unconventional life
and that's why you're asking these
questions you're asking
the right questions for the right
reasons
living an unconventional life in the
face of
the status quo and the status quo is
what to go 35 000
into debt to have this wedding that
you're not going to enjoy and the people
who go there
don't want to enjoy either but the
champagne fountain
[Laughter]
and gotta have it yeah and so so i i
really like that you're asking these
questions i'm gonna send you a copy of
our book everything that remains
it is really about these two guys me and
ryan
who started questioning the status quo
living an unconventional life which
really just means an intentional life
because intentional
especially these days is unconventional
so let's send you a copy of everything
that remains if you like our podcast
you'll like the audiobook version of
everything that remains it's my favorite
thing
we've ever written but also uh if you
don't want the audiobook we're happy to
send you the book book
or the ebook version of everything that
remains